she's the first not for the first time a
u.s secretary of state and an israeli
prime minister side by side affirming
their alliance but the smiles were
strained and even personal praise for
the u.s ambassador to israel was met
with what sounded like sarcasm it's
deeply committed to the relationship
between
israel and the united states
if it was a difficult meeting the cause
was clear israel's opposition to
reviving the iran nuclear deal which it
says will make it easier for iran to
attain a nuclear weapon
israel also opposes one of the moves the
u.s is reportedly ready to make to get
the deal done removing iran's
revolutionary guard corps from its list
of foreign terror organizations their
proxy the houthis just this weekend
carried out a horrific attack on saudi
arabia
i hope the united states will hear the
concerned voices from the region
israel's and others
on this very important issue his guest
tried to make the case that while the
preferred means may differ the goal was
shared there is no daylight between us
on the fundamental proposition that iran
must never be allowed to acquire a
nuclear weapon
and whether there is a return
to the jcpoa the iran nuclear agreement
or not
that principle will not change nor will
our commitment to it but as the details
of this long-negotiated deal solidify
the daylight between israel and the us
becomes ever more glaring and there are
differences too on a separate issue
israel's stance on the war in ukraine
israel has provided humanitarian aid but
its prime minister hasn't condemned
russia's invasion out of a public wish
to be a mediator and less public
concerns about any changes to russia's
role in israel's interests in syria
israel's foreign minister has condemned
the invasion and promised israel won't
be used to bypass sanctions but there's
been so far little evidence of that in
terms of policy
after a raft of israeli government
meetings a stop in ramallah in the
occupied west bank last year blinken
committed to reopening the u.s consulate
that dealt with palestinian relations so
far it hasn't happened
despite the crimes of israeli occupation
that have reached the stage of ethnic
cleansing and racial discrimination as
considered by human rights organizations
as well as its continuous aggressions
we don't find any party that holds
israel accountable
lincoln's visit is not yet over the
foreign ministers of the uae morocco
bahrain and egypt joining the israelis
and americans for a summit in the
southern negev desert a chance for
israel to promote its normalization with
some arab states and continue to press
the u.s on iran harry fawcett al-jazeera
west jerusalem